[Music]
you're part of like a little bit of a
celebrity golf would you say a little
group Group a group Don Cheadle myself
Sam Jackson Barry Bonds Johnny Gill
we're all members of the same Country
Club so so we play a lot yeah but I also
have a yearly game that I play with Don
Cheadle George Lopez and now Cheech
Marin and we call it the brownie cup the
brownie cup yes the sense where this is
going but I'm not a hundred percent sure
right tell me what do you think it's
going I'll let you know if you're
correct you play regular golf I'm not
under the influence of anything and then
later on you have a brownie no I thought
you were going to say it was the brownie
cut because we're black and brown no
okay no the brownie cuff yeah we're
young to be in Girl Scout yeah yeah we
are we play you hit the nail right on
the head you did your research we played
the first nine holes sober you know and
a couple of us have cataracts and you
know ailing ailments so we have
prescriptions for things and at the at
the on the eighth green we take a
special brownie and we ingest it yeah
and then we have two shots of tequila
and we play the next nine holes
completely wasted okay okay here's my
question yes what first of all do you
see a big difference in performance
between the first half of the tournament
in the second half
some of us play a lot better some of us
play a lot worse yeah ah case in point
Cheech Marin from Cheech and Chong yes
you would think he would be able to hold
on to a weed brownie
yeah Oh No you're kidding he could not
handle his THC he's a well you're saying
that that Cheech of Cheech and Chong is
a lightweight in charge the lightweight
is a preschooler yeah hair too what we
do yeah yeah so it's it's actually fun
to watch to watch him play don t you
took a 15 strokes on a par 3 that's how
quickly our game goes sometimes
but you have a lot of fun brownie cups
coming up in a few weeks and it's going
on either our seventh or eighth year
that's great yeah I just want to see
footage of it the second oconee why
don't you come play with this I'm sure
yeah yeah okay
you